we live in this culture where every
young person's desire
is to be on tick-tock and to blow up to
blow up on tick-tock
and here's what's interesting you have
made a big point of not participating
much in social media
you know and not getting that involved
in it and you're
massive on tick tock and it's nothing
that
you intended it's nothing that you did
did it start with
your role uh on one division yeah
yeah the crazy thing was before uh the
pandemic i was on social media and i was
like
you know i was active on it and i was
enjoying it but then during the pandemic
i read this
book by this like brilliant computer
scientist named jaron lanier
have you heard of him and it's not in my
head but no okay but
he talks about like just the dangers of
social media and how it's
uh you know destroying our democracy how
it's
making people angrier and meaner and
more susceptible to to lies and
conspiracy theories and i was reading
this sounds like oh my gosh this stuff
is really dangerous
so i deleted all my social media and
and i felt fine right and then yeah
you know just a few weeks ago i hear
from friends that i'm
blowing up on tick tock and uh and that
you know people are
like uh just you know honoring my
like all the work i've done over the
years and and showing a lot of love and
it's like now
i'm like social media is amazing
you know like i gotta get back on it
screw democracy
yeah yeah what's more important our
democratic process
or you getting some love for the work
you've done i think that's the most
important thing
i think it's uh without a doubt um you
know it's so funny because
what's what people have been doing is
you've been a working actor for a long
time and you've shown up
whether it's a small part or a
medium-sized part you show you've shown
up in a lot of places so what people
have done
is they've uh they've gone and found i
mean even the smallest
roles that you've done and they post
them
and they mash them together on tick tock
and it's become
a thing yeah i mean millions and
millions and millions of
hits views whatever you call it have
happened in the last couple of months
yeah which is nuts it's insane like what
they they found you did a role on the
office
and when i heard about this i thought oh
okay well maybe
you had an arc on the office it wasn't
an arc
you were barely in the office and they
found that character tell us about that
i mean i did uh
so uh this was like many years ago
it was the the final season of the
office i i got the chance to to play
uh a character named asian jim in
and like in like one scene during the
final season and
at that point the you know the
popularity of the show had been waning
and
and uh you know i was in and out in an
hour and i thought that was really fun
and then i just kind of i completely
forgot about it
and then um several years later
i'm like walking down the street and
this car drives by and a guy yells like
asian gym
and drives off and i like i'm thinking
like is this some like racist
thing that i don't know about
either you either a fan just saw you or
it's a hate crime
i thought it was a hate crime you know
because i i had forgotten about uh
my appearance on the office and you know
people would be walking up to me like
what's up asian gym i'd be like [ __ ] you
what are you you know and and then by
the way i want to apologize for greeting
you when you came here to the studio
yeah i did that and whatever i mean man
i was way out of bounds